[Music]
gucci
wealth and class have always gone hand
in hand the difference today versus in
dynastic times is that wealth is branded
that's why many people are pretty
fixated on being able to properly
pronounce foreign luxury brands
i'll be patroning them
louise waiting
again luis waited okay when you say lv
it's not nearly as sophisticated as the
ability to pronounce with a proper
french accent
[Music]
we're not just talking about luxury
brands we're talking about the ability
to navigate a luxury lifestyle and that
needs to be mastered like anything else
in
a life of the wealth in china is
self-made several hundred
billionaires
are self-made over a million
millionaires are self-made all the rich
in china are only nouveau riches
[Laughter]
the sophisticated woman is willing to
spend a lot of money on very expensive
articles
however she should spend her money
wisely
[Music]
bargaining in china is a mark of clever
resourcefulness
in china luxury is associated with
upward mobility forward momentum
progression in life it is an investment
that needs to yield dividends on the
journey towards greatness in restaurants
in shops
at retail stores people will look at
what bag you're carrying and that will
change the way they serve you
chinese like to sparkle but they don't
like to shine you have to on one hand
stand out that's projective but you also
need to fit in
so bling needs to be very understated
for example the mobile phone
take a look at the back of that apple
gold phone it's perfect it's matted gold
even i have been forced to use an apple
gold phone
[Music]
however the design inside the home is
significantly flashier more rococo
and who are you wearing today
[Music]
understatement has a different threshold
here
you can't
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you